يتخذ مجلس حقوق الإنسان التابع للأمم المتحدة
موقفًا متشددًا ضد النشاط الروسي في
أوكرانيا كما قد تتوقع،
وتقول المجموعة إن هناك أدلة مستمرة على
جرائم الحرب الروسية بما في ذلك الهجمات التي
تلحق الضرر بالمدنيين والهجمات على
المرافق الطبية والبنية التحتية للطاقة في
المنطقة.
اغتصب الجنود الروس وارتكبوا
أعمال عنف جنسي ضد نساء تتراوح أعمارهن
بين 19 و 83 عامًا وسمعوا
روايات عن
تعذيب ضحية تعرضت للتعذيب
بالصدمة الكهربائية
صرحت في كل مرة أجبت أنني
لا أعرف أو لا أتذكر شيئًا
قدموه  تعرضت لصدمات كهربائية لا أعرف
كم من الوقت استمرت، بدا الأمر وكأنه
أبدية، في بعض الحالات، كان التعذيب
يتم بوحشية شديدة لدرجة أنه
تسبب في وفاة
الضحايا، وتقول اللجنة إنها
تنظر أيضًا في النقل المزعوم لعمال
المناجم غير المصحوبين من قبل
السلطات الروسية  إلى الاتحاد الروسي الذي
ينضم إلي الآن من جنيف بسويسرا
هو يوسف صياد خان، وهو محامٍ كبير في مجال
الامتثال للحقوق العالمية
ومتخصص في القانون الإنساني وينضم إلي
الآن عبر الهاتف، من الرائع
وجودك معنا يا سيدي، فقط اختبر
الخط، هل يمكنك ذلك؟  تسمعني نعم أستطيع
سماعك رائع أه ما هو
رد فعلك على هذا التحديث الأخير
والنتائج التي توصلت إليها لجنة الأمم المتحدة،
النتائج
تؤكد وتعزز حقًا ما كان
الامتثال العالمي يبحث فيه منذ الغزو
الكامل أه من قبل روسيا
لأوكرانيا أه في  فبراير من العام الماضي،
منذ 24 فبراير من
العام الماضي، لم نقم بتوثيق
حوادث التعذيب فحسب، بل قمنا أيضًا بتوثيق العديد من
الجرائم الفظيعة بما في ذلك حجم
جرائم الحرب والجرائم ضد الإنسانية والإبادة
الجماعية المحتملة، ويتمثل دوري المحدد في
النظر في كيفية تقاطع هذه الجرائم
مع التجويع كأسلوب من أساليب الحرب
من حيث كيفية استخدام التجويع
ليس فقط في الحصار ولكن أيضًا كيف
يتداخل مع نهب
البنية التحتية للحبوب وكذلك أه التدمير وإزالة
الأشياء التي لا غنى عنها لبقاء
الأوكرانيين وجعلها عديمة الفائدة
السكان التقارير بالإضافة إلى
الفكرة المأساوية والقديمة القائلة بأن الاغتصاب
كان سلاحًا من أسلحة الحرب لفترة طويلة ولكن
اغتصاب النساء الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 19 و
83 عامًا هو أمر مسيء بشدة لهارينج
وغير معقول، ماذا يمكنك أن
تخبرنا أكثر عن  الاتهامات
بالعنف الجنسي التي ارتكبها الروس
أعتقد أنه في سياق
العنف الجنسي في النطاق الأوسع
لتجربتي في التعامل مرة أخرى مع ما يرقى إلى مستوى
جرائم الحرب والجرائم المحتملة
ضد الإنسانية، فإن وضع
الشباب على وجه الخصوص في الخطوط الأمامية
دون  ربما يكون التدريب المناسب أو
تحفيزهم من خلال تجريد
الآخرين من إنسانيتهم ​​هو في الحقيقة ما يؤدي أو يميل
إلى أن يؤدي إلى هذه الأفعال، وهي
شيء لدينا فريق متخصص
من الامتثال العالمي للحقوق بشأن
العنف الجنسي والعنف القائم على نوع الجنس والعنف
الجنسي المرتبط بالنزاعات والذي هو  التعامل
مع هذا الأمر ودعم مكتب
المدعي العام وكذلك
مكتب المدعي العام الإقليمي لتحقيق العدالة
لهؤلاء
الضحايا